I will compromise on some things but
then certain things I won't budge
especially if it's like for the overall
creative message of something you want
to change the shoes my clothes this is
more sexy I think I like this I agree
thank you that's pretty too yeah maybe
black gloves Yeah Yeah moradiva from
today yeah I think Danielle not being
here is happening for a reason because
this is just about me and to prove to
myself that I can do something like this
on my own without my whole team like
this path I had to go on by myself I
definitely like the black better yeah
I'm getting more confident every day I
have to like assert my opinion and say
exactly what I like
and I'm doing that and I got this